As you can see here, QRDA statistics
can be reported at one of three
levels of detail called categories.
These are all reported in
a CDA-compliant XML format.
As you can see here, the categories
are the individual patient level,
which could be a list of encounter dates
for that patient, patient lists, which
could be all the diabetic patients in a
provider's practice, or aggregated data,
which could be the average hemoglobin
A1c for all the diabetics in a practice.
We'll discuss QRDA and
other related standards,
such as the format for
the queries themselves, in Lesson 9.
For now it's just a standard vehicle for
reporting the results of population or
public health queries.